Robbin a particularly on Game of Thrones
we start at quite different times
actually because the writers and the
American producers are based in Los
Angeles I start with them in the writers
room we have a outline that's released
first and that's just released amongst a
very small group of people our show
runners and executive producers David
Benioff and Dan Weiss they sit and talk
the other producers and myself through
every scene of the new season then also
discuss any inspirations that they would
like the art department to take for for
that coming season and actually the
document that they released is fantastic
because even though it's not exactly as
the scripts are going to read scene to
scene from an art department perspective
they basically have everything we need
to know so it's enough to get us started
and then I would then go and do a scout
around our foreign locations and try and
determine any you know offshore work
that we'll be doing and then somewhere
around 15 weeks out historically the art
department has started and Rob you don't
we start at exactly the same time yeah
about 15 weeks out yes start out and
then my Deb says Deb's gives me the
outline that she's been given and I
specifically look at it from a sort of
step deck perspective and then as Deb
says we will then start sort of break
down the outline and then the scripts
are sort of introduced we start breaking
those down introducing the sort of
budget element to it and then we have
just discussions starter about how how
and what it's going to look like the
season and the worlds basically so yeah
I started about 15 weeks out as Rob says
any new worlds that we're establishing
any extra crew that we need to bring in
any specialty things that we're going to
have to specifically design what's going
to take the longest to make what the
lead times will be all that sort of
thing we we start negotiating all of
that through quite early actually yeah
it happens pretty fast yeah I think it's
very specific to Game of Thrones
actually just in terms of the beast that
is certainly it's trying to achieve film
finishes on a television schedule so
that's been something that's been quite
difficult
there's certainly originally to adjust
to was just the speed that these people
need to be able to work at
and the amount of decisions that are
made actually very quickly when we have
the shooting units and the to shooting
units running as well that's something
I've never come across on such a scare
and it's um yeah it's fast and certainly
by the end of every season we end up
with three or four units shooting at the
same time just to sort of sweep
everything up before before the season
ends so yeah I I don't I don't know of
anything else that would ever try and
achieve what Game of Thrones achieves is
it's just so ambitious in everything
that it sets out to do the thing that
Dan and David did best is they managed
to assemble a group of sort of
workaholic perfectionists all in the
same space and I think that's the only
way that the show the show gets through
I think the story actually I mean mine
sort of steer I mean my father was a
production designer my brothers have
just begun that's a production designer
now so I've always known I used to go
around all the sets with dad he used to
work in Los Angeles quite a lot he's um
did you know about 30 40 films so I sort
of went in to set decorate and as
opposed to production design I was more
interested in sort of the fabrics the
textiles and that sort of side of it as
opposed the drawer and aspects of it and
I used to go around with the set
decorators and someone father's jobs and
yeah if I sort of always had a feeling
for that really so see I started as a
junior and sort of worked my way up
really so
donc doing it for about 20 odd years now
so yeah nepotism at its best it's in
your DNA my DNA yeah it is this sort of
family tradition really so yeah yeah
yeah it's been great it's been great
yeah I mean for me I yeah it wasn't
something that I knew I was going to do
from a child or anything but I wouldn't
studied architecture after I finished
school after three years of that I
realized that that was during too many
straight lines so I went and studied a
theatre course and in Australia there's
a very famous - a theatre school called
the National Institute of Dramatic Art
and everyone from Baz Luhrmann Catherine
Martin Cate Blanchett all of those
people have gone through there so
there's a great sort of film tradition
even though it's inside this theatre
school and I was lucky enough to go
there and I graduated from there
just the right time when the film
industry in Australia was really booming
and to have had the experience in
architecture that I had meant that they
were looking for people who can draw and
so when the matrix and this is the first
matrix arrived on Sydney's shores I I
joined the matrix art department and
from that point on I never worked in
theatre again I think it's a
collaboration really it always starts
obviously in the script and for us on
Game of Thrones it's very much driven by
Dan and David Rice's and showrunners
every show that I've ever done is being
very directed driven in the same way
like I've been fortunate to work on very
visual projects and now when I worked
with Baz Luhrmann on Moulin Rouge or
with Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu
this was on 21 grams like both of those
directors have incredibly strong visions
so I'm used to working in sort of world
building as it as it were so I've been
very fortunate to work in those kind of
environments where you know you're
trying to sort of push against the rules
a bit and expand what you're trying to
do and I think it fits Game of Thrones
perfectly because it you know we've got
a reality yeah but it's just to the left
of what we know now and I think it's
through establishing the reality that we
have in the show that then it allows us
to believe in dragons and and I think
that's that's part of the key to exist
yes yeah we work a lot by instinct
whatever actually feels good for that
family might feel good for that house
yeah
tends to be the one that we go with and
I have to give the producers all the
credit in the world because they have
never said no to a location based on
difficulty because often times locations
might be difficult to access they might
need us to you know put in a road of our
own in order to get there in order to
bring all the machinery and or whatever
and that's never been a problem for Game
of Thrones if the location provides all
of the visual wonder that that the show
needs then then they make it happen and
I think that's extraordinary
Game of Thrones is so so busy
and everybody's you know stretched we
work in constant each day new sets like
Deb said we've got you know builds model
makes and concepts so it's just trying
to yeah make everybody sort of at ease
and not feel under pressure so it's a
lot of multitasking as well
lots of multitasking because you're
dealing with yet locations abroad we got
Spain Spain this year when we had Spain
last year so it's juggling all the Bulls
as well I think also we have to remember
that we're essentially working with
artists yeah and all of these people in
their own right are incredibly talented
people who could you know have
successful careers on their own doing
their very specific thing but to be
fortunate enough to have those sort of
people with in the game of thrones art
department means that we can draw on all
of their abilities all the time so it's
also giving people the breathing space
so that they can do their best work and
when you're under this sort of time
constraints that we have sometimes
that's very challenging it's like please
be as creative as you can you've only
got five minutes
so yes yeah sometimes that's it seems
like it's very counterintuitive but we
all feed off each other actually yeah
and and we all have each other's back
and we've been working together for a
long time so I think that all helps
enormously yeah you know most projects
you start you do you know eight nine
months and then you sort of split and
you might not see those people for a
year or two or not at all so bran gamer
friends it's nice to have been working
yet with the same people for four or
five seasons now I think so
yeah I mean we actually all genuinely
like yeah it's not it's not forced at
all no no no it's been brilliant the art
departments so vast it encompasses so
many departments in itself but then
probably the one that I would work with
the most outside of our our direct team
would be special effects yeah I think
there's a big special effects crossover
on game of Rangers with all the elements
and that yeah the different sort of
battle sequences and yeah special
effects it's a huge crossover so we have
meetings every month don't worry where
everybody gets around the table with
HIDs and head of departments you know to
talk through the various scripts and the
various episodes and the different
directors that's the other thing on game
efrain's we have some times up to five I
think five directors at one
point five directors five different DPS
or so you know especially our department
wise you know we've always sort of laugh
because it's we're covering every single
director every single DPS needs it's not
just you know any specific thing we have
to cover the whole broad base of
everybody so that's what's quite tough
so when you when you've got some
directors and DPS just concentrating on
their one episode they sort of you know
have to remember we're doing yes we
always we laugh about it constantly
because a director comes in and they
might be shooting one or two episodes
we're obviously doing the whole season
so yeah it's it's all kings and poor
ones you've just got to deal with
whoever's right in front of you yeah at
that time yeah and work it accordingly
because the thing is is that we shoot
all of the episodes at once as well it's
not like we shoot it by episode and move
on and we shoot it by location so we
might be shooting at sea episode three
one day in Episode eight the next day
yeah and we just moved through so in any
of the 600 script pages that we'll have
we could we could shoot any of those
anytime you know I remember some days
and particularly when I first arrived
having a lineup of directors outside my
office door and I do
and I just thought my head was going to
explode and it's because some of the
because of the changeover between
directors and directors of photography
like Deb says sometimes if we're on like
a Winterfell set for one day it might be
an episode you know foreseen and then
we'd have to strike it revamp it for the
next day and then another director comes
in another director of photography comes
in they've got different needs different
lighting requirements and that happens a
lot where we have one set and set up for
a different team one day and another
team we have to set up in the next day
so it's constantly shifting and changing
in Luke II you know just one set isn't
it that's quite challenging sometimes
it's like an extreme sport and and I
sort of tend to think of it in those
terms where we're we're in it as a team
and we're like these sort of bobsledders
and we're you know we we spend all sort
of season training and you know ever
since I've been there in season four it
builds you up to a point where you're
ready to go for season seven yeah
all of the work from previous years
builds up to the point that you're at
and then you're careening down the hill
and trying not to wipe out on the corner
so if you make it to the bottom it's
fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]